Namur dasa bhagavad-dhu, bhagavad-dhu, samasambuddhasa.
Hommage au Bouddha, le noble, le bienheureux, pleinement éveillé de par lui-même.
J'ai pensé que cette soirée, nous allions essayer de traiter ce qu'il s'agit de ne pas être soi-même,
Ce qui est très confus.
C'était confus pour les contemporains du Bouddha.
Les Jains, les Jains qui étaient les contemporains du Bouddha,
Donc le leader des jaïnes était un contemporain de tout ça.
Et les jaïnes disaient, nous et les brahmins, nous croyons à une âme éternelle.
Et les matérialistes n'y croient pas.
Et les bouddhistes n'ont pas encore décidé.
Donc c'était... ça induisait beaucoup de confusion.
La première chose à comprendre, c'est d'où vient le bouddhisme.
C'est encapsulé dans le mot dukkha.
Et ça, on trouve la réponse dans le mot dukkha.
L'ensemble des enseignements est basé sur ce mot dukkha.
Il est même allé jusqu'à dire tout ce que j'enseigne c'est dukkha et la fin de dukkha.
Donc dukkha est une vue de la vie humaine.
Donc, en tout cas, c'est une vue de la vie humaine.
Cela veut dire difficile à supporter.
Et en général, c'est traduit par souffrance et de manière plus juste encore par le fait de quelque chose qui est insatisfaisant, qui ne peut pas être satisfaisant.
Oui, et un écrivain le appelle stress.
Et une autre traduction, c'est stress.
Bien sûr, cela inclut toutes les peines et toutes les souffrances physiques et émotionnelles de la vie.
Et cela inclut également tous les plaisirs et les joies de la vie.
On the grounds that they arise and pass away.
Avec la compréhension qu'elles surviennent et disparaissent.
Donc, de manière ultime, ce sera toujours insatisfaisant.
Vous tombez amoureux de quelqu'un et vous êtes au septième ciel.
Et après quelques mois, ça s'en va.
Ça s'en va comme un mauvais oeil.
Comme un oeuf qui s'éteint.
Vous savez, comme un oeuf qui s'éteint après un moment.
Un oeuf.
Un oeuf qui s'éteint.
Un o
Et bien sûr, c'est l'impermanence de la vie elle-même.
Donc, dessous, dans toute existence humaine, il y a cette menace de la mort.
Et vous pourriez dire que la grande majorité de nos joies et de nos plaisirs sont des tentatives d'échapper à la mort.
Donc, l'un des enseignements de base, c'est ce non-soi.
il revient après son awakening, son enlightenment, quand il voit ses 5 anciens compagnons, la première chose qu'il leur enseigne, c'est Dukkha.
Et il y a un livre qui, en fait, le croit en leur demandant constamment, avez-vous jamais entendu me parler comme ça ?
Et dans une des écritures, il demande sans cesse à ses anciens compagnons, est-ce que vous m'avez déjà entendu parler comme cela ?
Donc le premier discours qui est connu comme le tour de la roue du dharma, de la roue de la loi.
C'est tout à propos de Dukkha.
Et tout concerne totalement Dukkha.
Ce sont les quatre nobles vérités.
Donc il y a Dukkha, c'est une évidence fondamentale.
Donc c'est une évidence qui vient de l'expérience directe que l'on fait de la vie, et enracinée dans cette expérience directe.
Il n'y a pas de métaphysique.
Pas de métaphysique.
Donc, ce n'est pas une histoire de Dieu ou de choses comme cela.
C'est simplement que la vie, en général, c'est horrible.
Et puis, la deuxième vérité nobile, il pointe à la cause de cela, qui est cette mauvaise relation, désirant que le monde nous rende heureux.
Et la deuxième noble vérité, c'est ce à quoi il pointe l'origine de la souffrance, c'est le désir erroné de demander au monde de nous rendre heureux.
Et alors, il fait aussi une déclaration très forte, il dit qu'il y a une fin à la souffrance.
Il ne dit pas quelque chose du genre, comme Freud, votre vie sera un peu meilleure si vous pratiquez.
Je ne connais aucune thérapie qui dise qu'il y a une fin à la souffrance.
Et la raison en est qu'aucune d'entre elles ne va à la racine du problème.
Et la quatrième noble vérité, ce sont les moyens, ce qu'il faut pratiquer pour réaliser la fin de la souffrance, pour l'accouplir.
Et la première, c'est au moins de comprendre au moins intellectuellement les enseignements du Bouddha.
Et cela a bien sûr des conséquences sur notre attitude à nous.
Et une attitude, c'est la manière dont nous nous relions au monde et aux autres.
Donc, en général, on dit que c'est aller de l'égoïsme à la générosité, de la cruauté à la compassion et de la haine à l'amour.
Et une fois que l'attitude est correcte,
The right speech, the right action, the right livelihood follow naturally.
Et quand cette attitude est correcte, alors la parole juste, harmonieuse, la right speech, right action, right livelihood.
Et l'action juste, harmonieuse, les moyens de gagner sa vie juste, harmonieuse, viennent tout seul.
And supporting this is of course the
la bonne méditation, la bonne pratique.
Et bien sûr, ce qui soutient cela, c'est la méditation juste, la pratique juste, harmonieuse.
Donc maintenant, quand il revient, ce qui s'est passé, c'est que il a rencontré ses disciples, pardon, ses amis, et puis il a ouvert une discussion avec eux.
Donc je présume que c'était l'après-midi.
Ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'il a revu ses amis, il a commencé à discuter avec eux.
J'imagine que c'était l'après-midi, peut-être le soir.
Et le lendemain, ils vont faire leur tournée d'aumône de nourriture pour avoir à manger.
Et quand ils sont revenus, ils ont mangé et ils ont resté.
Ensuite, il parle de ce Noxel.
Et quand ils reviennent, après qu'ils aient mangé, qu'ils se soient reposés, alors ils commencent à parler du non-soi.
Donc, il n'a pas parlé du non-soi avant qu'il n'ait compris toute cette histoire autour de la souffrance du corps.
Et à la fin de ce discours,
Et à la fin de son discours, l'un de ses étudiants a eu cette réalisation.
Et il l'a appelé Anya Kondanya, qui veut dire Kondanya, celui qui sait.
Il aimait bien donner des titres aux gens.
Par exemple, Sariputta était le général de la dhamma.
Par exemple, il a appelé ce petit couteau le général du dharma.
Alors, c'est quoi ce discours ?
Parce qu'il est crucial, il essaie d'expliquer ce non-soi.
Ce n'est pas ce qu'il a dit en fait.
C'est un...
Le discours, bien sûr, c'est une manière qui a été faite postérieurement de mettre sur une certaine forme ce qu'il a dit.
Il a commencé par dire le corps, cette forme, est non-soi.
Il a dit, si le corps était soi, si les formes étaient soi, cela ne conduirait pas à l'affliction.
Nous devrions, dans ce cas-là, pouvoir dire au corps, je voudrais que tu sois comme ci, je ne veux pas que tu sois comme cela.
Nous avons une impression d'être au contrôle du corps.
Parce que nous pouvons bouger les bras, faire du tai chi ou faire du yoga.
Mais lorsque nous investiguons combien de contrôle nous avons sur le corps,
En réalité, quand on investigue quelle est la quantité de contrôle que nous avons sur le corps, c'est très superficiel.
Je peux le souhaiter de toutes mes forces, mais je ne peux pas faire pousser des cheveux sur mon crâne.
Il y a eu un moment où j'ai vraiment voulu que le cheveu restait sur mon tête.
Il y a une époque où j'aurais bien aimé que mes cheveux ne tombent pas, mais ils sont tombés quand même.
Donc à un âge très jeune, j'ai déjà compris le non-soi.
Donc ce que le Bouddha utilise pour continuer ses discussions, ce sont ces cinq khandhas.
Donc on pourrait dire que l'être humain a une intersection.
C'est comme regarder un être humain d'une manière particulière.
À l'être humain.
Ici on a le corps.
Mais ce corps physique est seulement une partie de cette catégorie.
L'autre partie est la façon dont l'esprit expérimente le corps.
L'autre partie, c'est la manière dont l'esprit fait l'expérience du corps.
C'est l'endroit où l'esprit touche le corps.
Et c'est au même endroit, dans le même espace.
Donc le corps et l'esprit sont en contact juste à l'endroit qui est la base de nos sens, comme par exemple la rétine.
Et même là, on a peu de contrôle, très peu.
Si une personne est color blinde, c'est tout.
Si une personne ne voit pas les couleurs, alors c'est ça, c'est comme ça.
Donc l'expérience que nous faisons du monde est limitée par nos sens.
basé sur les cinq sens et si l'on parle du sixième sens qui est l'esprit lui-même donc dans la compréhension du bouddhiste quand on entend le son ici à l'oreille
En réalité, il n'y a pas de son, il y a juste de la pression.
Et ça, on peut en faire l'expérience.
Et alors, l'esprit s'en saisit et cela devient un son.
Il en fait un son.
Et après, il lui donne une signification.
Ah, la cloche.
Et ensuite, il vous dit pourquoi vous entendez la cloche.
Et après, il continue en disant, pour quelle raison tu entends une cloche ?
C'est l'heure d'aller à la méditation.
Donc, il y a tout un processus, mais juste à la base, au fondement, l'information est minime.
Pareil pour la vue.
Il y a un très bon livre sur
Il y a un livre très bien d'une maître dans la tradition du roman, Mahasi Sayada, qui est malheureusement morte jeune, elle avait 40 ans.
Elle a écrit un super petit livre.
Et dedans, elle décrit ce dont on fait l'expérience en réalité au niveau de la vue, autour du monde.
Elle dit que c'est comme la peinture du pointillisme.
Le pointillisme.
Oui.
Les petits points.
Elle a dit que c'est comme dans le pointillisme, c'est juste des petits points comme ça.
Et c'est l'esprit qui crée l'image.
Donc, c'est ce que nous appelons l'ankanda, traduit comme un aggregate.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle un ganda qui a été traduit par le terme agrégat.
Yeah, a heap.
Is there a word for a heap?
A heap.
So, the second one,
Et là encore, c'est divisé en deux, les ressentis physiques et les ressentis mentaux.
Et les ressentis physiques, c'est ce que nous comprenons comme
les conséquences des émotions dans le corps.
Il a dit ça aussi, c'est pas sous notre contrôle.
Pourquoi est-ce que je ne peux pas me dire quand je suis en colère, je ne sentirai pas la colère ?
Oui, encore mieux, bien que je sois déprimé, je ne veux pas ressentir cette déprime.
Et même si je savais que j'étais déprimé et que je pouvais ne pas ressentir la dépression ou la déprime, ce serait chouette.
Mais c'est évident que je ne peux pas faire ça, donc je ne suis pas en contrôle.
de mes émotions, comme je les ressens dans le corps.
Et bien sûr, c'est pareil pour les ressentis physiques.
Si vous avez, je veux dire, la douleur que nous recevons de la posture de s'asseoir, vous ne pouvez pas la dire juste pour s'en aller, elle reste.
Par exemple, la douleur que nous avons dans l'incise, on ne peut pas juste lui dire de s'en aller.
Elle reste.
Elle refuse d'obéir.
Donc tout ça revient à pointer sur les questions, qu'est-ce que nous voulons
Mes ressentis.
Et c'est la même chose avec toutes les perceptions, les concepts, les images que nous avons à l'esprit.
Une fois que nous avons, disons, même une chose simple comme la perception d'une chaise, vous ne pouvez pas vous en sortir, n'est-ce pas ?
Et même une chose simple comme la perception d'une chaise, vous ne pouvez pas vous en débarrasser, n'est-ce pas ?
Donc on a une conception de la chaise, elle a quatre jambes, un dossier et quelque chose sur lequel on se laissait.
C'est ça, vous ne pouvez pas vous en débarrasser.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous en débarrasser de ce concept.
Vous pouvez le nuancer, le modifier en regardant des chaises de type très différent, mais vous ne pouvez pas vous en débarrasser.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous en débarrasser.
Je ne pourrais pas dire maintenant, je n'aurai plus le concept de la chaise dans ma tête.
Et bien sûr, on n'a pas envie de ça, sinon il faudrait réapprendre ce que c'est qu'une chaise.
Et donc, cela pointe de nouveau à la question qu'est-ce que c'est quand je dis c'est moi ?
Si c'était moi, je devrais être capable d'être au contrôle de cette chose que j'appelle moi.
Donc, de nouveau, on cherche une définition de ce que je veux dire par moi.
Et puis, il y a le prochain agrégat qui est Sankara
Et après, il y a l'autre agrégat qui est le sang capable.
Donc ça, c'est toutes les habitudes que nous avons créées à l'intérieur de nous, pour nous, à travers des actes volontaires.
Et nous savons désormais, à travers notre pratique, nous débarrasser de nos habitudes dont nous aimerions nous débarrasser très difficilement.
Et pour dire la vérité, même quand quelqu'un est complètement libéré, il garde certaines de ses habitudes.
Parce que la libération, en fait, c'est le fait d'être libre de ses habitudes.
Donc même quelqu'un qui est complètement libéré, il verra l'habitude arriver et disparaître.
Mais elle n'aura pas de pouvoir de prendre leur attention.
Il y a un cas, une fois, où un brahman a joint l'ordre des moines bouddhistes.
Et il utilisait un langage, quand il croisait des gens d'une caste inférieure à sa caste de Brahman, le langage usuel pour s'adresser à des gens de caste inférieure.
Et ils se sont plaints au Bouddha.
Et les gens disent au Bouddha, c'est quand même vraiment anormal, il nous appelle d'une manière dégrindante, comme en tant que personne de classe inférieure.
Ce n'est pas normal.
Il ne devrait pas faire ça parce qu'il est...
Et le Bouddha a dit non, c'est une habitude, mais il n'a derrière aucune intention négative.
Il ne veut pas vous faire de mal, mais il le fait.
Ces habitudes pénètrent profondément notre psyché.
Elles y sont installées.
Et puis finalement, il y a la conscience.
La conscience ici, ce n'est pas l'intelligence.
Ou encore mieux, un écran.
Comme l'écran de votre télé ou de votre ordinateur.
Pour pouvoir faire l'expérience de quelque chose, il faut qu'il y ait une base sensorielle.
Et il faut aussi qu'il y ait un objet qui puisse être ressenti.
Et qui doit apparaître sur cet écran.
Et si un de ces trois caractéristiques, je ne dis pas SP, manquent,
Par exemple, si vous êtes dans une pièce totalement noire, vous ne verrez rien.
Ou si vous êtes endormi, votre conscience est endormie, vous ne voyez rien.
Et si vous êtes enceinte, vous ne voyez rien.
Si vous êtes aveugle, vous ne voyez rien.
Et ces trois facteurs doivent être là pour que quelque chose puisse être connu.
Et le Bouddha a décrit la conscience en se référant à ses bases sensorielles.
Donc, il y a la conscience visuelle, la conscience auditive, etc., et aussi la conscience de l'esprit.
Et quelle est la quantité de contrôle que nous avons sur cette conscience ?
D'une certaine manière, jusqu'à un certain point, nous avons un certain contrôle puisque nous pouvons faire attention à quelque chose.
Mais une fois que nous avons conscience de quelque chose, on ne peut pas s'en débarrasser.
Si j'étais en train de marcher sur la rue et qu'il y avait un boule dans un champ, et que j'étais conscient de la boule,
Donc, par exemple, je marche sur la route et il y a un taureau dans le champ, et j'ai conscience de l'existence de ce taureau dans le champ.
Et quand je regarde le taureau, je ne peux pas me dire, à partir de maintenant, je n'aurai plus aucune conscience de ce taureau.
Parce que cette conscience ne dépend pas de moi.
Ah, c'est dépendant de la base des yeux.
Elle dépend de la vue.
Et de nouveau, c'est une question de quand je dis moi, quand je dis je, je fais référence à quoi ?
Ce n'est pas une définition de moi, c'est que je suis en contrôle de moi.
Est-ce qu'une définition de moi, ce ne serait pas je suis au contrôle de moi ?
Où est-ce que le pouvoir réside ?
Donc, si il y a quelque chose d'éternel...
Si je ne peux avoir aucun contrôle sur ces cinq Khandas, alors de manière évidente, s'il y a quelque chose d'éternel, ce n'est pas à l'intérieur d'eux que je vais le trouver.
Donc, si il y a une âme éternelle, ce n'est pas
Donc s'il y a une âme éternelle, ce n'est pas ce corps, cette personne, cette personnalité.
Et alors, il l'approche d'une autre manière.
Si il y a une âme,
S'il y a une âme éternelle, alors l'une de ses propriétés, c'est qu'elle ne peut pas changer radicalement.
Elle ne peut pas être et ne pas être.
Elle ne peut pas arriver et passer.
Elle doit être continuellement.
Elle ne peut pas survenir disparaître, elle doit être continue.
Et alors il demande à ses amis, alors moine, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Est-ce que ce corps, il est permanent ou impermanent ?
Oh, impermanent !
les conversations socratiques.
Et bien sûr, il demande cela de tous les cinq canards.
Les ressentis, les perceptions, les habitudes et la conscience.
Et puis il dit maintenant, si quelque chose n'est pas impermanent, est-ce que
Si quelque chose est impermanent, est-ce que c'est satisfaisant ou non satisfaisant ?
Oh, insatisfaisant, c'est dur.
Donc, ça ne va pas donner une satisfaction permanente.
Le mot ici, dans le Pali, c'est, bien sûr, dukkha.
Est-ce dukkha ?
C'est Dukkha et A Dukkha.
Comme ça, il fait avec les cinq Khandas.
Donc, quelle que forme, quel que corps, que ce soit le passé, le futur ou le présent, interne ou externe, que ce soit court ou fin,
low or lofty, far or near, all of it, with real insight, according to reality, is this mine or is it me?
Can you try again?
No.
Small bits, ok.
Therefore, whatever body is, past, future or present,
quoi que le corps soit passé, présent ou futur.
Interne ou externe.
C'est vrai qu'il soit ou rugueux ou délicat.
Au bas.
Lointain ou proche.
Tout cela doit être regardé avec la sagesse adaptée avec la réalisation juste.
Donc adapté à la réalité.
Ceci n'est pas moi, ceci n'est pas moi et ceci n'est pas moi-même.
Donc, si l'on se met en phase avec la réalité, ce n'est pas moi, je ne suis pas cela, et ce n'est pas à moi.
Il est très clair que ce que nous expérimentons à travers ce corps, que ce soit des ressentis, des émotions, ce n'est pas moi.
Donc il est très clair sur le fait que quoi que ce soit que je fasse l'expérience à travers ce corps, des émotions ou autre, et bien ça ne peut pas être moi.
Et les moines étaient ravis
Dernier des points de cet exposé.
Et alors que le Bouddha a fait cet exposé, alors le groupe des cinq moines était libre de toute souillure et de tout obstacle.
Et à cette époque-là, il y a eu alors six personnes totalement libérées dans le monde entier.
C'est un bon discours avec un gros succès.
Il y a un autre discours.
Il y a un autre ascétique qui s'appelle Vachagotha.
Donc il y avait un autre ascète qui errant, qui s'appelait Vachagotha.
Il y a quelques discours qui concernent cet homme en particulier.
Et nous le voyons grandir spirituellement jusqu'à ce qu'il rejoigne finalement l'ordre, car il appartient à un autre enseignant.
Et on le voit croître spirituellement jusqu'à ce qu'il finisse par rejoindre l'ordre des moines bouddhistes, parce qu'avant il était avec un autre enseignant.
C'est la seule fois que le Bouddha est demandé, dans les scriptures d'ailleurs, est demandé directement, est-ce qu'il y a un self ?
Ou est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un self ?
Je le sache, c'est la seule fois dans les Écritures, en tous les cas, que Bouddha est interrogé de manière directe, est-ce qu'il existe un soi ou non ?
La question est, Vénérable Gautama, est-ce qu'il y a un soi ?
Et le béni était resté silencieux.
Ah, donc il n'y a pas de soi.
Ah ben oui, alors ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de soi.
Et le béni restait silencieux.
Et Bhakti Gauta s'est levé de son siège et il est parti.
Il était dégoûté.
Toujours dans la confusion, est-ce qu'il y a un soi ou pas ?
So now Ananda, who was a constant companion of the Buddha for the last 20 odd years of his life, he asked the Buddha, he says, why didn't you answer him?
So he said, well, if I had said there was a cell, people would have put me in the camp of eternalists.
Et le Bouddha a répondu, si j'avais répondu qu'il y avait un soi, alors les gens m'auraient mis du côté du camp des éternalistes.
Ceux qui croient à l'âme éternelle, quelle qu'elle soit.
Donc, si j'avais dit qu'il n'y a pas de soi, ils m'auraient mis du côté des annihilistes.
Comme par exemple les scientifiques matériels.
Et puis il dit, si je devais dire qu'il y avait un self, il ne serait pas en tune avec mon enseignement sur l'origination dépendante.
Et si je disais qu'il y a un soi, ce ne serait pas en cohérence avec mon enseignement sur l'interdépendance originelle ?
Tout survient du fait de quelque chose d'autre.
Il n'y a rien dans cet univers matériel, phénoménologique, qui soit sa propre entité.
Tout est interdépendant.
Si tout est interdépendant, rien n'a son propre être.
Si tout est interdépendant, alors rien n'a son propre soi.
Son propre être.
Donc si, étant interrogé sur le fait de savoir s'il n'y avait pas de soi, et que j'avais répondu « il n'y a pas de soi »,
Le vachagota tout confus aurait été encore plus confus.
Le soi que j'avais l'habitude d'avoir avant n'existe plus.
Donc il serait parti dans un état de confusion au sujet de savoir s'il a un soi ou pas.
Donc c'était mieux de rester silencieux.
Donc ce que cela nous raconte, c'est que le Bouddha n'est pas intéressé par la métaphysique.
Il parle de nirvana comme quelque chose de permanent.
Qu'il n'y a plus de souffrance dans le nirvana.
Et pourtant, il n'y a pas de soi.
Comment pouvons-nous comprendre cela ?
C'est la question.
Donc, dans notre méditation, on a accès à un poste d'observation, à l'intérieur de nous.
Et de cette position,
En général, au niveau du troisième œil.
Donc on peut voir tout ce qui arrive, on peut ressentir tout ce qui arrive dans le champ de notre conscience.
Donc il y a bien une séparation entre...
ce qui est l'objet de conscience et ce qui a conscience d'eux.
Et quand on est dans cette position, l'organisme continue à travailler, il n'a pas besoin de nous.
Parce que quand je suis dans cette position,
Je fais l'expérience de moi comme étant celui qui observe, celui qui ressent.
Je suis celui qui fait l'expérience et tout le reste est l'expérience.
Et dans cette position, j'ai quand même un sens du moi.
Je fais l'expérience de moi comme étant celui qui observe, celui qui fait l'expérience.
Donc, on a cette conscience qui est fondée sur les six sens.
Vous vous souvenez, c'est les cinq sens physiques et l'esprit.
Donc cette conscience sort de cet organisme psychophysique.
Et pourtant a quand même un sens d'elle-même.
Et donc ce sens du soi doit survenir sur cet écran de conscience.
Donc ce sens du soi est aussi un objet.
Donc qui que ce soit que nous soyons, nous ne pouvons pas être cela non plus.
L'image dont je me sers, c'est de regarder une vitrine pour acheter quelque chose.
ce qu'il y a dans la vitrine.
Mais je peux aussi me voir dans le miroir de la vitrine.
Et cette image que je vois de moi dans la vitrine me dit à quoi je ressens.
Mais rappelez-vous, c'est l'autre côté, n'est-ce pas ?
Le miroir.
Ce n'est pas la façon dont les gens nous voient.
Mais souvenez-vous, c'est à l'envers, cette image.
Ce n'est pas du même sens que les gens nous voient.
Ah, c'est à l'envers, hein ?
Oui ?
C'est inversé.
Avez-vous... avez-vous... avez-vous... avez-vous connu le truc des deux lumières pour voir comment les gens vous voient ?
Non ?
Si vous regardez dans un lumière, et vous avez un autre lumière, et ce lumière regarde dans ce lumière, oui ?
Et vous regardez celui-là,
Et il y a peut-être un choc.
Ce ressenti ou cette expérience d'être l'observateur nous dit quelque chose à propos de l'action d'observer.
Dans votre méditation,
tranquille, apaisée, calme.
Devenez très conscient du fait d'être l'observateur.
Et juste pour un moment, faites l'expérience, reconnaissez que c'est la conscience qui se regarde elle-même.
Et après, demandez-vous ce qui était là-bas.
Et après, demandez-vous, mais qu'est-ce que c'était qu'il y avait là, en fait ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est qui est à l'intérieur ?
Donc maintenant, on a un très gros problème.
Parce que dans la tradition bouddhique, il y a une dispute, une grande dispute.
Ah, parce qu'il y a deux expériences qui sont reconnaissables comme une évidence.
Est-ce qu'il y a deux expériences qui sont reconnues comme le nirvana ?
La première, c'est quelque chose qui ressemble à un black-out.
Et la qualité et les caractéristiques de ce black-out, ce n'est pas comme aller dormir.
Donc quand les gens reviennent de cette expérience, leur manière de percevoir le monde, leur perception du monde est changée de manière subtile.
Et cela change leur vie.
L'autre expérience est celle d'une conscience qui n'est pas touchée par aucun des sens, les six sens.
Et l'autre expérience, c'est une conscience qui n'est touchée par aucun des six sens.
Sans limites.
Et pleine de lumière.
En d'autres mots, un éveil.
Donc, c'est directement du Bouddha.
Je quote le Bouddha.
Donc, certaines personnes ont cette expérience, et elles...
Donc ça c'est directement le Bouddha qui l'a dit, je suis en train de citer le Bouddha.
Donc certaines personnes ont fait cette expérience.
Et donc ils ont dit que le Nirvana c'est cette expérience de pur être.
Et depuis 2500 ans ils se discutent.
Et il n'y a pas de solution à ce problème.
Mais j'ai eu une grande fortune.
Il était un de mes étudiants.
Il était nouveau pour moi, en fait.
Et il avait une expérience particulière, qui, devons-nous dire...
Mais j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un de mes étudiants, qui était un de mes nouveaux étudiants, qui a eu une expérience qui était intuitivement juste.
Il est allé dans le blackout.
Et puis il s'est réveillé dans cette pure éveillance.
Et il s'est réveillé dans cet éveil total.
Et après, il est rentré dans les six consciences de cet organisme.
Peut-être que les deux côtés ont raison, mais ils ne peuvent pas se mettre d'accord.
Mais ici, bien sûr, nous avons un problème de définition.
Donc, le temps que le bouddhisme se développe en 2500 ans,
On a vu que le concept du Nibbana est devenu des mots par exemple comme la nature de Bouddha.
Et l'idée c'est que quand on est cette nature de Bouddha,
Et à travers cette forme, elle se développe dans son propre... Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce mot ?
Et à travers ce médium, cet organisme, il vient de connaître sa propre nature vraie.
Et à travers ce média de cet organisme physique qui est le nôtre, psychophysique qui est le nôtre, il arrive à connaître sa propre nature.
Donc, le Tathagata qui vient de...
Il s'appelait lui-même Tathagata.
Cela veut dire celui qui est allé là-bas, celui qui a transcendé.
Je ne sais pas si j'ai fait encore plus de confusion.
Je peux seulement espérer que je n'ai pas fait plus de confusion.
Je peux seulement espérer que je n'ai pas créé plus de confusion.
Et que grâce à votre investigation attentive, vous allez découvrir par vous-même la vérité en la matière.
Plus tôt que plus tard.
Typique, non ?
Il y a en réalité un autre discours qui est délicieux.
Un moine est très malade.
Et il y a un autre groupe de moines qui ne cessent de lui envoyer un moine pour lui poser une question.
Et il s'éveille avec ça et sort de la chambre et s'en va à ces autres moines.
Et il en a ras-le-bol, alors il se lève de son lit et va voir les autres moines.
Et la question qu'il a posée est, est-ce qu'il est attaché ?
Est-ce qu'il a des attachements aux cinq candas ?
Et son réponse est non.
Donc ils pensent qu'il est un arabe.
Et sa réponse est non, donc il pense qu'il est un arabe.
Mais il dit non, je ne suis pas un arabe.
Bien que je ne sois pas attaché aux cinq agrégats, j'ai toujours le sens du « moi ».
Il est au stade de ce qu'on appelle le non-retour.
Et comme dans les discours du Bouddha, alors qu'il est en train d'expliquer cela, il devient pleinement libéré.
Et comme dans les discours du Bouddha,
So anyway, we haven't got that lot.
So if we take a half an hour break.